Oh Nana welcome once again what a
dramatic end of the game that you had
did you know that you were losing at
some point and then I mean
I didn't like my position exactly where
I I was losing I don't know but if she
would have taken if takes G5 instead of
F5 I didn't like my position okay so
walk us through the game what were the
critical points did you know the opening
yeah because I had a similar opening
with the Wagner I mean a couple of weeks
ago and during the women's Grand Prix
and I didn't take on F4 after Bishop F4
here and then after the game after that
game I analyzed computer suggested
Bishop F4 and Bishop G4 and that's why I
played it today what did you play Queen
is seven uh Queen if actually I don't
remember exactly now because this this
is I know I think I took but I didn't go
Bishop G4 now I remember okay I took but
I didn't go Bishop G4 I went Knight B6
if I remember correctly so but uh Bishop
G4 this I remember for sure that
computer was suggesting that's why I
played Bishop G4 and actually after all
these exchanges okay continue
uh I liked my position
after 94 I thought I had no problems but
then after
she after Rook E5 when she played I
couldn't find any plan for me I was
thinking to play like A5 A4 but I
thought it too slow I liked her move
Bishop F3 very much
because this bishop F3 I think it
prevents my C5
counter play and also now she wants to
come with this Pawn G4 H4 F5 so I I
couldn't find any any good plan for
black hair I don't know I was I I think
I I I thought here more than 20 minutes
but yeah but what I should I should make
a move so that's why I played Rook AC 8.
otherwise I I don't know I was thinking
technique but I didn't know what to do
man so yeah after
um yeah here already I I did like my
position and okay I have a question for
you here because did you consider that
white could leave The Rook on E5 sure of
course maybe try something yes I was
considering actually here I think G5 I
was going to play
so you consider these options I think
this was a very nice continuation but
then uh no no after okay um F5 and when
uh continue please uh here I think F5
was wrong
from her side because after F take
divide that's what I was calculating I
should play Knight either f8 or B6 and
then she exchanged these Rook send them
Queen E7 and I have I think losing
position yes because we have to show our
audience that the main threat in this
position is actually Queen E6 yes let's
say we make a move like so Queen is six
is winning on this spot so or maybe he
should even even queen of three yes
probably
I mean when when she when she came back
like even here I could take GTX F4 but
after Queen is excited I was losing no
all right Queen E6 Bishop P6 I was
calculating this line
and what no it's F6 yeah
he considers that you have to give an
exchange exchange B7 I thought this was
losing for me that's why I didn't
I didn't go on this this line
yes it's not easy for a human eye to
understand why is this worse actually I
agree with you completely
no no but it's
I understand of course so if five
negative six yeah after F5 uh yeah after
night F6 I already
started thinking survival surviving here
we started to breathe a little yes it is
and then I think okay five still still
in tough position so let's get back to
that at least my night is in the place
so and I think that the most dramatic
thing happened here
the computer shows yes that white is
winning after rookie seven yes okay
seven I was going to play what what I
was thinking I think Queen G4 I was
thinking
or what no no no he wants to give
checkbook yeah yes and then the problem
is that this variation I think that
maybe both of you missed is the ultimate
no it's like Queen
of uh Queen this uh yes and if I Quinn
disturb and if I go Queen to seven well
then he starts collecting collecting
yeah
and what did you feel here actually did
you know that you were after Queen A3
you're winning three it looked very
strange after that yeah
yeah I noticed Quincy it and yeah
already I thought it's raining for me
so well it's a very important Victory
Nana yeah she was in time trouble and
that's why yeah she I didn't see this
I'm always asking a few questions you
know which has nothing to do with the
game uh well you are one of the most
famous representatives of the Georgian
uh chesco so I wanted to ask you what
were the chess Traditions when you were
um growing up is there some something
that you would like to share with us
actually I've shared several times this
my chess story because my name Nana my
father gave me after Nan Alexandria
because at that time when I was born
just was like hugely popular in Georgia
because we we had this golden Georgian
women team day one I think
several times Olympic Championship also
we had our famous world champion
so just was very popular and yeah my
father was
um fun fun of them and that's why he
wanted me to become
chess player in the world champion
so the Franklin from the beginning it
was decided that I should become just
for something he is proud of you know
and when you won the world Blitz
Championship also what did he say
unfortunately my father passed away
before that yeah but this achievement it
really was the
our biggest achievement in my chest
career so I'm really very proud of this
thank you Nana yes you I think you make
us all proud and especially Georgian
fans they support you I know this we
share a lot of success and especially
hope for another medal in uh well in
individual events and also in the team
events thank you very much a question
for you uh Nana if you don't mind we
just had Carol Meyer she's the executive
director of the USCF we talk about
women's chess and how to make chess more
popular for women in America in your
home country of Georgia women flocked to
the game and you have a great cultural
tradition of supporting chess in Georgia
how can America
help women play chess like and make it
as popular as it is in Georgia Almira if
you could ask the question to uh yes
yeser asks so how can uh American uh
well American chess American society
help women more you know and to do the
same as like Georgian chess tradition
[Music]
actually
nowadays it's it's very different as it
was before because
before when I when I was playing like
when I was a kid that time we didn't had
much choice you know but nowadays your
children kids they have many different
options to choose not only chess
but in America I think here especially I
mean what's this here they are doing I
mean they are very much promoting chess
I think and I think they should continue
like this and actually in the first day
when we met
Mr singfield and mrsfield I I asked them
maybe
in the future they will organize some
strong women tournaments rapid and Blitz
English I think it boosts
just in America because I love flying
European kids and I think for the
viewers for the I mean Spectators
it's very entertaining to see I mean
women playing rapid and Blitz so yeah
oh it's a very nice suggestion thank you
uh
wrap it in blitz so uh Rex and Genie uh
pay attention here but